I'm Okawada from the Tokyo Aikidokai.
I'm presiding over the "Aikido and Japan Martial Arts Summer Festival".
As you can see,
many people are enjoying the Aikido training.
Before that, they were also able to watch some budo demonstrations.
During such events, if Aikido or only one type of martial art is being practiced
I feel that it leads to a narrower view of the world.
Thanks to an event like this, I hope many people will feel the spread of martial arts.
I also wanted to hold this kind of event
so that people could expand their own practice and their world.
I hope we can continue to have the opportunity to mix with many people in this way.
Thank you very much.